enviadas aquí en Holly Head en gales
desde el brexit han tenido que cumplir
un pesado papeleo de la Unión Europea a
pesar de que los camiones se dirigen a
Irlanda del Norte parte del Reino Unido
Ese ha sido uno de los problemas
centrales del protocolo del brexit sobre
Irlanda del Norte que Londres y Bruselas
dicen haber resuelto la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Legend y el
Primer Ministro británico Richie sanac
presentaron el llamado marco de Windsor
que delinearía un nuevo capítulo en los
lazos Unión Europea Reino Unido
el acuerdo de hoy ofrece un Comercio
fluido en todo Reino Unido protege el
lugar de Irlanda del Norte en nuestra
Unión y salvaguarda la soberanía del
pueblo de Irlanda del Norte
tenía
el nuevo marco de Windsor respeta y
protege nuestro respectivos mercados y
nuestros intereses legítimos
y lo que es más importante protege los
logros de paz del acuerdo del viernes
santo de
belfast good Frida
el acuerdo llega tras más de un año de
tensas conversaciones sobre el protocolo
de Irlanda del Norte 25 años después de
que el acuerdo de viernes Santo pusiera
fin a tres décadas de conflicto
el marco de Windsor sobre Irlanda del
Norte introduce una nueva vía verde para
las mercancías que permanezcan en Reino
Unido garantiza la plena disponibilidad
de alimentos y medicamentos autorizados
en Reino Unido que garantiza que los
futuros cambios en el IVA para el resto
del país se apliquen a Irlanda del Norte
también limita la supervisión por parte
del tribunal de Justicia europeo de la
Unión Europea de normas relativas a
Irlanda del Norte y la asamblea de
Irlanda del Norte podrá impedir la
aplicación de las nuevas leyes de la
Unión Europea
el shinge que ganó las elecciones en la
provincia el año pasado celebró el
acuerdo y pidió a los uninionistas
democráticos que pongan fin a su boicot
al reparto de poder los unionistas dicen
que verán si el acuerdo cumple las
expectativas que incluyen el papel que
tendrá el tribunal de justicia de la
Unión Europea aún no es un acuerdo
cerrado los diputados británicos votarán
a pesar de que en Irlanda del Norte no
hay un gobierno desde febrero pasado